I'm not from the property world I'm a
chef started in the Kebab shops in
Grimsby I then got my first job in
property when I was about 24 in Spain
worked seven days a week and it was when
the market was booming and everyone was
buying overseas literally one pound
event and made a million profit well
that's a story and a half how many
properties have you currently got around
about 125 so the five houses we sold
them each house sold for 550. don't get
the deal first get the money first but
I'm like get the deal first put yourself
under the pressure and then the money
will come in total it's gonna work out
at about 20 million wow that's huge mate
and I go see the developers and I say if
we sell all of these in one day give us
a big discount the last development we
sold was 79 units each one priced at
about 600 000 per unit we sold them in
two hours
well firstly how was Tony Robbins Tony
Robbins was that was amazing I saw you
on stage as well yeah I was so scared oh
amazing so it was just one of the things
so they'd ask me if I'd do a testimonial
and I went yeah you know I want to give
back a chance to say thank you to him
yeah and then the opportunity came to
Tech my 14 year old son
and he's he's lovely obviously but it's
my son but he's little like me so he
looks like he's you get sometimes people
say is he a bit younger and uh so I took
him on stage and imagine saying you know
he's 14 he's spoken from the 10 000
people wow on stage imagine what that's
going to do for him yeah that's life
that's awesome so you're doing massive
things in real estate yes no you own
like a lot of properties how many
properties have you currently got if
you're talking about in the company and
personal name it's around about 125.
that's great man yeah and you know
complexes and stuff and yeah apartment
blocks and you've been in full-time in
property since 2005 2005 I got into it
selling property yeah and then brought
my first property in Spain which was a
nerve-wracking experience yeah you know
it's different language
a different legal system and if you know
if I'm honest I'm not from the property
world I'm a chef so that's really I
started in the Kebab shops in Grimsby
okay that's where I learned how to cook
yeah you know so completely different
background just to go from being a chef
did a few sales jobs and then got my
first job in property when I was about
24 yeah um in Spain selling property in
22 different countries
so it's a massive learning curve yeah
and my boss at the time he
pushed us so hard I mean he's a great
inspirational guy
and pushed us but we worked seven days a
week
15 16 hours a day traveling around doing
back-to-back exhibitions and it was when
the market was booming and everyone was
buying overseas yeah so yeah that was my
experience how Universal are the
strategies in property because I found
that the basic primitive like brr for
instance and development and service
accommodation is pretty kind of
universal you're you're doing stuff in
lots of different countries you've been
involved in property transactions in 23
different countries how transferable are
the skills like if you know how to do it
in the UK can you do it in Portugal can
you do it in Spain I find it easier
right so I think the UK is when I've
come to your to your webinar to your
Watching You on YouTube and coming to
the academy coming to the one pound
event which I actually loved yeah um I
just hoovered up all the information and
I find it really hard in the UK because
I left the UK when I was 17. yeah
um but implementing that in Portugal
Spain Florida we just I literally just
switched everything in my brain and
I can remember doing your one pound
event
and an opportunity appeared it was so
like divine intervention some people
call it and I went to Africa and I went
to Ghana with a friend of mine great
place amazing the most underrated
country on the planet yes and it's a
great holiday destination and people
don't know it yep people don't know
about Africa it's insane and the
investment there so what are we doing
there are you investing or holiday my
company had sold a property to gentleman
lovely guy their friend of mine
um Duncan off Dragon's Den
and sold him a property went along to
his charity event and I just kept
putting my arm up and the bidding went
up and it was a trip to Ghana with a an
amazing charity called Operation Smile
and I remember the bidding just went up
a little bit higher a little bit higher
and and I thought I'm gonna miss out on
this opportunity to spend
10 days in Africa helping children
and I just really went for it and put it
on a credit card
flew out to Africa I remember it was
just as he was going to be on I'm a
celebrity yeah and we had to delay it
slightly flew out to Africa and I didn't
know what I'd landed in you know landed
Africa was so different I was young I
was scared and then
kind of being with Duncan he made him
way safer and his lovely wife nagora and
we carried the first baby through she
got the operation fixed a smile and the
process of seeing that just changed me
forever that was like a life-changing
moment completely yeah and you just see
it and then after that I sat with him
and said would you ever invest in
property with me and he went you found
the correct development and I remember
what you taught me at the one pound
event so I went out and found the
correct development it was up for
can I run through the numbers yeah
please do so it was up for sale for a
million and it was five houses and I
negotiated the price down to six hundred
thousand literally and I love
negotiating yeah and and he said but I
want 600 000 today and I didn't have the
money
so I negotiated back up to 650 gave us
two years to pay for it and then I had
to do a similar thing get some money put
it down on a on the development reserve
and then run around and find the
investors yeah that was pressure I think
that's the right way around though it's
It's Tricky but people don't understand
it sometimes do they no but when I said
the right way around yeah yeah I heard
somebody once say
don't get the deal first get the money
first but I'm like no no get the deal
first put yourself under the pressure
and then the money will come yes because
you can't find money without a deal yeah
and people think that getting the
money's hard but I actually think the
hardest bit is getting the right deal
yes and then once you've got the right
deal then get the money and and you do
put yourself under pressure yeah so how
much did you have to raise uh for that
one because we couldn't use the banks
and I didn't have enough training to be
honest to use the banks and we didn't
need to yeah
um so the numbers on that was 650 for
the land about a million to build it
finish it it's all finished now yeah
it's done yeah that was done in after
your first one pound event so thank you
so much oh wow literally one pound event
and made a million profit
well that's a story and a half it was
insane and then yeah I should have
signed up for the Academy then that's my
biggest regret is not signing up then
yeah because yeah where would I be now I
mean please where I am now I'm very
humble
um but I could have probably helped more
more of people and are you selling off
the apartments now then so the five
houses we sold them that was in 2015
right and we won the developer of the
Year award for that one
each house sold for about 550
and all of them houses are worth over
800 they're five minutes from kin to
Largo got swimming pool huge big
townhouses four bedrooms four on Suites
plus an extra bathroom luxury finishes
and we just I mean it wasn't easy First
Development yeah now I can imagine and I
did that before we owned a house in
Portugal that's a massive massive to go
into right
absolutely huge how long did that take
then what was the process process on
that was probably about
16 months yeah then the profit was a
million just over a million wow mate
huge fact thank you it was a
life-changing experience that is
ridiculous that's cool so why how did
you get all the team in place to do that
like how did it
um so I used another friend who got me
the building crops and I trusted him
he'd been a developer before yeah so I
said can you help me with this he went
yeah sure I mean I'd helped him
previously in different things with his
business and
um he's a lawyer so he checked all the
contracts did everything for me I just
had to keep things moving and be the
communicator between everyone and then
we sold all the houses I've got the
sales team to sell the houses now we
rent them out yeah so we're still
involved in the development right
because you manage them now yeah yeah
one of them we would manage for rentals
the other four they didn't want to rent
them out which I'm a bit like you could
make I mean them houses mate 50 60 70
000 Pals my only regret is not keeping
it yeah I should have refinanced the
whole thing me and Duncan could have
made three four hundred thousand a year
how do you get Duncan then as your
investor like that's that's a pretty
huge thing you know this guy on Dragon's
Den who's really famous how did you
manage to get him to invest in the deal
how did you build that relationship I
came from Rightmove I advertised
properties on right move and then
Rightmove contacted me and said Duncan
wants to buy a house and we sold him a
villa one of my staff did praising yeah
he still got it yeah it is great he's a
great guy to be around and what are you
doing now then so are you still doing
those types of big developments or yeah
so I I've been doing personal
development for years yeah 11 years and
so I retired at 40. I don't run my
company now so I've got a wonderful CEO
amazing lady called Angela Warren she
looks after the company all the
companies there's about six businesses
wrapped into one and she looks after
that so I retired at 40. went off spent
some time with my mum in the UK spent
some time with Children got a little bit
bored and couldn't figure out what to do
next so I came back to your events yes
and I brought some friends with me
you're like it worked last time
yeah let's make it a bit bigger and
you've also got stuff like um having an
apartment Block in Portugal or something
yeah so again after
doing your event an opportunity impaired
to buy
seven blocks of apart so I went back
negotiated with a bank they you know
they went yeah their bank repossessions
they were finished fully furnished ready
to rent they're already rented I went
and smiling because it was your mum who
helped me and I was on the phone to her
and I said how can I get the rental
yield and turn it up and 20 minute phone
call I was like right moth the bank
didn't even make me go to the branch
it's like Donald Trump writes in his
book if you owe that much money to the
bank they come to you yeah and I was
like this is insane so I just yeah put
my hand out took the opportunity and
brought 118 Apartments wow so it's just
a bit crazy that is madness I mean you
must have pretty big balls to be doing
that level of deals kind of got to
analyze the downside and there was no
downside to it you know there's always a
risk yeah but I'm buying apartments that
uh that should be up for sale for 250
000 just on the building cost alone so I
took all the the knowledge from the
first build and I've done quite a lot of
properties since then you haven't just
gone five to 118 right I've done lots of
individuals my own personal house I've
sold big developments so I I know how to
sell you know I've got a big company big
sales team there's very little downside
and so I brought wow so you bought for
how much do you pay for the Block in
total it's going to work out at about 20
million wow that's huge man so I didn't
think it I just I don't know because
I've been selling big developments yeah
because the real kind of the big ones
are we sell developments in Lagos and I
negotiate a fantastic deal for all the
clients and I go see the developers and
I say if we sell all of these in one day
give us a big discount yeah and that's
big for me because I mean there the last
development we sold was 79 units
each one priced at about six hundred
thousand per unit we sold them in two
hours
and it was just and that was I can't
remember but 55 million so the the
little development the 20 million one
feels little because you've been used to
handling it even though it might not be
your deal yeah it's like my
brother-in-law Ben who is a uh chartered
surveyor yeah and he's he was working
for like Coca-Cola and companies like
that doing massive projects yeah as with
my wife she's also a Qs she was working
for she also worked up for Coca-Cola and
doing a huge and then when I married my
wife Amanda had gotten with them they
were doing massive deals but not for
themselves for other people but then
when they left and came and worked with
me they massively leveled my business
because I'm used to thinking oh I'll buy
this house and do it into a HMO you know
get seven rooms and my wife and Ben my
brother-in was like come on man at least
you need some bigger stuff than that I
can't even buy a factory there maybe so
now I've got these big developments but
my the people around me like my wife and
my brother they don't see them as big
developments yeah them it's like small
fry because they're used to doing other
stuff and I think I've learned that
sometimes big deals although they are
potentially more risky if you don't know
what you're doing because you can if you
do it wrong you can go bankrupt on a
huge deal but just as difficult to do a
big project is to do a small project and
it's the same amount of effort and
energy yeah I've had some right pain in
there in the bum headaches with like a
hundred grand house you know 100 grand
house spend 50 Grand doing it up revive
200 Grand make 50 Grand profit and I'm
thinking that's more effort than this
deal where I got a piece of land and
built six houses so it's really
interesting how much do you think your
Tony Robbins and personal development
Journey you've been on for the last 11
years the mindset has played into your
property business it's there I mean I
owe yourself massive thank you you know
and and you've been a true inspiration
to me you really are I really appreciate
that thank you thank you and Tony
Robbins has been a massive inspiration
so it's and it's literally just YouTube
that I follow so because I get confused
so I'm just saying there's loads of
online teachers but you just know yeah
just stick with me and Tony yeah and I
prefer Live Events yeah so I don't watch
I don't do that many virtual events I
don't watch that many YouTube videos I'm
I don't generally read that many books
and because I'm not a great reader I
left school at 15. you got the sex
you're dyslexic yeah so I can't even
type messages I send videos to people
which I think it's just fantastic yeah
I've noticed man it's great though you
see the energy and it's it can be
misconstrued anyway a text message
Garnet yeah whereas where was it a video
or a voice note video voice note I do
voice notes but you can speed them all
pass on like Mickey Mouse
five foot two with the voice
no yeah
so what
what Chris like what's your driving
force behind doing doing all these deals
ah so grew up in Grimsby and
I don't know not a hard childhood I
wouldn't ever say that but we didn't
have any money we didn't have enough
money for food so that's what made me
into a chef
and I used to cook from the age of eight
or nine
and then we we lost the house Dad went
on the scene uh I had a few stepdads
from amazing people and we moved to
Cornwall and she could never buy a house
again so it was the mortgage broker who
let her down so we had a great time we
grew up in Cornwall for me late age of
11 until I was about 17 and cornwall's a
great place to live but the property
Market is so expensive
and we could never get back on the
ladder so it was always ingrained in me
property is a great investment property
is a great investment and I remember my
parents telling me that the first house
they ever brought was 1800 pounds in
Grimsby and then they sold it for 6500
and that always stuck in my mind yeah
and it was just there and I thought well
you need two things you need and I know
you know I have been taught by people
when they say you need six or seven
streams of income so I was always
thinking I want to make my life safe I
want to make it better for other people
people around me
I mean my real estate team in Portugal
none of them have ever worked in real
estate I found them in supermarkets I
found them in and at bars and
restaurants that's interesting it's just
really enjoy doing that and really
helping people yeah and they're amazing
people yeah anyone who picks up the
phone to my company they get the best
service hand on heart say best company
in the Algarve Portugal it's probably
the largest independent company in
Portugal now we don't have a you know we
don't have you know like a brand I don't
like being tied to anything and I didn't
I wanted Independence so we're
independent I remember Re Max chasing me
on another trip to Africa when we went
to the orphanages and in the beginning
he said by the end of this trip you'll
sign up a Remax by the end of it you
shook my hand anyway keep doing what
you're doing and that was like
you know it made me realize that we're
on the right path for the last 10 years
ago and also your kids as well I mean I
love the fact that you're bringing them
down to the events and and you're right
you can't be being in the room live and
I think a lot of people there's a lot of
people that sort of now are living in a
very online world aren't they and people
think oh you know if you want to learn
about something just study online which
is great and I've got online courses and
I do YouTube content yep but you can't
be going down live how did you hear
about the property investors crash
course the one pound event that I was
running wow I think it was in
Peterborough yes 2018. maybe it was 2017
2018 yeah and I you know I've done loads
of events and I flew to the from
Portugal flew to the UK turned up and it
was packed I was amazed I thought
there'd be 50 people and there was over
a thousand people and I I was working
out the numbers in my mind thinking cat
you know how can you and I paid 47
pounds sat on the front Okay so it
wasn't quite one
yeah and then got your book and did the
property event it was two days
and nearly signed up for the Academy but
I wasn't quite ready because you know I
had to fly from Portugal my kids were
young yeah yeah after that
you changed everything in my business
like my rentals company the influence
you had on the rentals company was
massive because they sped everything up
I learned how to just advertise better
and everything you know when you tell us
about service accommodation I just times
that by 100. we've got 144 rental
properties and then you would tell us
about
different aspects of the business and I
would just you know like the hmos and
then I'd convert that into something
else what do you think separates the
winners and the losers in business I
think you need a bit of a routine so in
the morning
I wake up in the morning and just have a
little bit you've got to wake up happy
you know I wake up music you know with
my kids I put music on in the morning we
dance relaxing song it's loads of fun
yeah they go to school in a positive
mood which then lifts my mood I love
dropping my son off at school me off
amazing conversations and now I'm
getting into a bit of Fitness what do
you kids think there so how did you find
trying to teach them about money and
business and personal development when
they're at the age of their act so what
I do I generally
um because I'm not the best sales
trainer or anything and when I train
people to sell I show them so I'll take
them to an exhibition I'll do the first
two or three sit Downs with clients and
then so off you go and I'm here to
support you so I do the same with my
children I mean with my son
I did a little thing where I wanted to
smile on pictures so I would say happy
face sad face funny face from when he
was really young just to get a nice
picture of him yeah and that's kind of
you know he's kind of controlled his
mood you know I always say to him
breathe breathe because he holds his
breath and you can't hold your breath
when you're in a situation and you're
making a big decision like you sat with
a bank buying 20 million euro
development
you've got to remember to breathe yeah
you're right 100 and then I took Jacob
to see Tony Robbins I'd love to bring
him to your event I'm Daisy I took Daisy
as well and he kind of sat there and I
looked at him and I went you look bored
he went he's saying everything you say
wow and I didn't realize I'd picked up
so much yeah that's it's so true yeah
and kids do not only did you pick up a
lot but the fact that they they remember
yeah you know that's crazy he went off
to do the firewall he did high fives to
700 people then he went off to do the
firework and after at the end he went
you meant to celebrate you know it's a
bit like the arrow that you do and
um he walked off at the end of the
firework did you like it yeah it was all
right done scarier things I was like I
was scared during the fight yeah yeah so
you're raising some Warriors then I'm so
impressed with him yeah that's awesome
what would you say then if you were
talking to somebody that was wanting to
get into property yeah um and they were
starting from scratch I mean what would
be your advice to them I'd tell everyone
go to your course and then just watch
you on YouTube because that got me into
it like the couple the other day I sent
a little video to you I went there you
go when it wrote down name wrote down my
phone number said ask me if you've got
any questions but go to your course
watch on YouTube so you're the key point
for anyone in the UK if you did
International that would be major
benefit yeah I mean we do get a lot of
people doing the online stuff and even
it's crazy even at the the programs I
call even at the one pound events how
many people do fly in it's Madness
acceleration if you get to come on a
plane to get here and there'll be like
five percent of the room yeah but yeah
we cannot plan meanwhile there's someone
saying when are you next in Grimsby they
don't want to drive to Manchester I know
that drives me inside yeah that's but
that's very common that I get that I
probably get 30 messages a day from
people saying like when are you next
coming to Liverpool because I've seen
that you're only in Manchester and Leeds
and I'm thinking if
a couple hours Journey will stop you
you're a stoppable person yes so in
business in business there's a lot of in
fact the whole definition of an
entrepreneur is solving problems it's
firefighting it's putting out problems
so what's gonna happen is if that's your
mentality you're gonna fail anyway
because when when you get a really good
property deal you'll go oh it's a bit
far well I'm not going to finance for it
though oh the mortgage broker said no
there's constant challenges in business
yes and you need to have the mentality
of saying actually that's normal and as
a as an entrepreneur we're going to
solve those problems and that's how we
get success I mean I I love one of the
things you did which was make it their
problem and I use that in everyday life
yeah I'd smile and I get away with it
better than you because I'm five foot
two you have to crouch down a bit but
like go to the airport and they're like
no you can't get a window seat and I'm
like hello so if I could get a window
seat what would be the solution yeah and
they're like ready okay yeah yeah
exactly make it their problem if they
say oh no we don't do company let's we
haven't got any properties available and
just okay you know so so what do I need
to do then oh I've got an amazing story
for you it's a sad one my brother's been
sick for some time he's had three
illnesses
and well gets me every time he's better
he's okay but um yeah I mean he was sick
when I was 14 and then he was he had
really bad cancer when he was 35 I'd
sort of help him through the cancer took
nine months off and then 11 weeks ago he
had a heart attack and I flew to the UK
I was really nervous you know and to be
honest he I walked into hospital and he
acted like it was nothing you know he
went it's not as bad as a cat so the
heart attack this time was nowhere near
as battle you know he went yeah and a
heart attack I went you're not working
again there's no way you're working he's
a school teacher giving up his life for
20 years for the government and they you
know they're just like
keep being a school teacher they said
when you went back to work it's like the
poor guys had a heart attack cancer and
there's not many people in the world
that survive three major illnesses like
that I always say it's the luckiest guy
alive because he's alive and he's got
the best sense of humor you'll ever see
so I'm in Cornwall and I'm thinking he
can't work anymore I'll get him some
money I'll go and see some real estate
agents yeah and I took this wonderful
lady her name's Claire down in Cornwall
and she took me out she found me a
property for eight to five thousand
pounds with a two thousand pound a month
rental yield on it and I was like that's
amazing I spent one day with her and I
gave her a free holiday out of it so
she's going to come to Portugal and see
us and given the Villa for free for a
week so it's just what goes around comes
around yeah you know they help you you
help them one of the things I've noticed
about Eucharist and I've actually
learned from you is that to be super
successful in business you don't have to
be ruthless you don't have to be
hard-nosed you know you don't come out I
know it's a friend of yours but Dragon's
Den there really heart-nosed and mean
and you don't actually need to be like
that in real life no to be extremely
successful in fact being kind and
compassionate I think helps you you know
Richard Branson for example I've I've
met Richard Batson a couple of times and
is probably one of the kindest soft
heart you know most compassionate people
but actually it's not contradictory to
being also extremely successful yeah
having lots of money doesn't mean you're
hard-nosed and trample over people
um I think money reveals who you really
are it doesn't uh it doesn't change you
because I was worried when I started
laying business from a Christian
background yeah I was thinking like you
know do I even want to be rich you know
because aren't rich people greedy and
jerks and stuff like that but actually
money gives you options doesn't it and
that is something I want to talk to you
about so I have to go into Africa to see
the orphanages in Kenya and then
recently just being in Africa with the
Tony Robbins people whereabouts were you
there in Zambia oh beautiful I've been
there 11 times I mean just because when
I first went to Zambia again like you
said you go out I went out my church
sent me and and you go out because yeah
I want to make a difference but you come
back different yeah yourself you know
you go out to be a blessing and end up
coming back blessed come back you know
it's great that you're doing a lot of
works you know overseas and help people
that are less fortunate yeah what would
you say has been the hardest from your
business you run a lot of businesses
real estate doing your developments and
your agency work you've sold hundreds of
deals as well what's the biggest
challenge that you face would you say
probably the biggest one was
um some people call it imposter syndrome
yeah and you're like do I belong do we
belong in this environment because you
know I've got no formal qualifications I
left school at 15. my first little
business and I would always forget this
was I persuaded my mum to buy me an ice
cream van
and that's how I got to know Duncan that
was a bit of a report and I persuaded my
mum had an xr3i if you remember the Ford
Escort I said sell that let's go to a
car auction as you brought me an ice
cream man and I was terrible at it it
was like a first little business what a
business to have yeah I've heard that
they're quite
protective about their patches yeah like
if you set up an ice cream van and
someone's already doing it they'll like
knee cap you or something you know
they're pretty can be scary yeah I used
to get my mum to drive it and I used to
save the ice cream's in the back wow I
see that a lot as well with I didn't
interview James Khan or someone Dragon's
Den oh yeah and there's a lot of
patterns when you get people that are
very successful in business you look at
them when they're a kid most of us did
paper rounds yeah did you have paper out
I didn't get my screenshot though so I
had a car wash business so and then I
figured out that I remember one like one
lady paid me with a boiled egg and then
it reminded me I've got last for the 50p
to clean the car and then I got some
friends to help me yeah and paid them
25p oh entrepreneurs do you think that
they're born or are they are they made
I don't know I mean so I had 42
different jobs before I started my
company 42 jobs 42 jobs used to be a
chef in the winter well cook I don't
know if you'd call that chef but then I
did I did have a massive achievement and
when I was young I became the youngest
head chef in France
um I was 17. I've known that I'd have
said we'll have some lunch afterwards
you could maybe make a meal it's been a
while barbecue
and then then there used to be a holiday
wrap so I worked in Spain I can see that
I can see you being a holiday rep
there's always a fun yeah yeah yeah I
can imagine that and then when I was
traveling around Australia I did try
going to University but just one for me
it's interesting as well I think the
world is different now because a lot of
people say to me like oh my parents
telling me to do this and the advice in
2023 it's to me it just seems awful but
it's probably because it worked in 1993
yeah but the world's different now I
mean the fact that you had 42 jobs the
old school way is go to school go to
college University whatever get learn a
trade or get a degree and then get a
good job for life it's just an exist it
doesn't exist tell me a person that has
a good job for life in 2023 because I
kind of got the status I think from I
have to Google this but from memory by
the age of 40 the average person has 21
jobs yeah so the amount of times you
made redundant or you have to switch or
the the environment becomes toxic and
you have to you're forced out or
relocate so the idea of getting a degree
and getting a good job for life it
doesn't exist no and also it's the same
story with money in the bank you know I
mean they used to give you a lot of
interest of your money in the bank yeah
not going back that far you get five
percent returning you might that's not
bad yeah Alex are you lucky if you get
0.5 of your money so putting money in
the bank and getting a degree and
getting a good job for life and buying a
house paying down the mortgage even
buying a house I mean now the average
house in the UK is around about 280
Grand if you're buying a property as an
investment your deposit is going to be
25 so with your stamp Duty your legal
fees you talk about 70 grand
to buy a house to rent out who can save
70 grand in a job if you're in 40 Grand
or even less the average salary is 30
grand mine if you're paying away tax and
then what not you're left with a couple
Grand a month but if you're renting the
average rent is a grand then you've got
your bills and whatnot you know even if
you don't eat you're looking to save 500
pound a month which means you're going
to be waiting 10 15 years to save a
deposit on a house so how do you break
out of that rat race mentality and and
you know explain to the old generation
that you know parents stuff that doesn't
work anymore because it just doesn't the
system is completely broken and rigged
yeah I mean the biggest thing for me is
traveling you get to learn new
experiences you get to meet new people
and it's taking opportunities with
traveling is key I mean you need the
mindset I mean I'm now going to the gym
every day I take my son to the gym and
my daughter loves swimming dancing so
you gotta get your Fitness up there you
gotta get movement
energy energy is key it is energy is Big
energy big Bank big yeah get the music
on get dancing all right let's go yeah
people people don't understand that yeah
they'll come to some of my training and
they'll be thinking you know oh man
Samuel's asking me to high-five somebody
yeah High music what's this but it's
like now you've got to have high energy
yes you know it's not about you know
just sort of like studying and being
studious and it's about having high
energy because if you've got I don't
know if I can get people into that state
then when I say to them right now pick
up the phone then you know what it's
like yeah you're probably making people
call agents yeah downloads make deals
happening but if you're in that studious
mindset uh detail and getting all your
ducks in a row waiting for all the
traffic lights to be on green before you
leave the house if you're in that
mentality you're not going to be
successful no no you got you've just got
to go for it really go for it get the
music on get dancing you know jump up
and down I love that jump up and down 20
times get a rebounder do some bouncing
but yeah I mean I mean doing this for me
this is my kind of payment I know some
of the programs we you know there's
Investments and stuff but the real
payment for me as a trainer is this sat
down with people like yourself from all
different backgrounds telling me their
story of how I might have been a small
part or a big part of their Journey you
know the real big thing for me me
um is you know the properties the money
the success but it's what you do with it
what I would like to say thank you by
saying is what I'm currently doing is
I'm helping out an orphanage in
Albufeira and using all the success from
that to build them a beautiful garden
it's quite a big Garden okay so I turned
up there at the orphanage I've known
them since just after the one pound
event the first one and I used to go in
at Christmas I used to dress as Santa
put a bed on give him some presents and
I always wanted to do more and just
before covid hit I wanted to go in there
and refurbish the orphanage and covered
it and nearly wiped me out like it did
with a lot of people and I finally got
around to going back and they'd closed
the orphanage down and they've moved
them all to a bigger orphanage in
Albufeira 44 children there and I walked
it then if I didn't say hello see some
of the kids who I've known from years of
previously
and
they said to me yeah we've got a quote I
said how can I help you you know I know
you don't need help but if I could
assist you with anything and they said
well we're trying to get the garden done
we've been quite 250 000 Euros to do the
guy and I went no no no no no no we can
do this for about forty thousand yeah
and if that
so every apartment we sold of the 118
Apartments a thousand ghosts in a pot
we've got 67 000 Euros sat there ready
to go
and then I got my Builder mate Carl I'm
like come on you're doing the garden he
turned up we went oh my God we've got a
refurbished the entire building yeah it
could be here for three years
I'm looking at one of my best mates so
we're going to refurbish the garden give
them a place to just relax it's got an
amazing Sea View and we're going to put
a swimming pool in and we've given an
internship to one of the girls she's 19
she works in our office training to be
an accountant so it's amazing it also
makes the job satisfaction of doing your
business so much better when you know
that it's you're not just gonna be able
to provide housing for people and you're
also you know you're helping more people
that's that's awesome talk to me about
your staff hiring process there you
mentioned that you find people
waitresses and yeah is that because you
want to give people opportunity and
equal the playing field or is it because
they actually make better workers and
they're harder workers and what is it
well I like people who've been in the
service industry because they're like me
if anyone ever turns up and they go yeah
I've been a holiday rep I know what
they've been through right so and then
it's easy to switch that into property
yeah and then just look after people
yeah like if you go I've only got two
offices in the Algarve if you go in any
of my offices they'll look after you
like amazingly and they know about
property investing you know like
Portugal I don't buy in the UK because I
think the interest rates are too high in
Portugal the interest rate's around four
percent that don't differentiate between
investors or lifestyle buyers so
bringing in a good team
train them on that and it's literally
just shown the way yeah so you get an
intense training without really because
you know it's like training people yeah
you have to get the message and right
rather you know I'm better at showing
people I can't do what you do and and
stand up and drain people for two days
I've never really done that but what I
can do is show people how to do it yeah
and sit with them on a one-to-one basis
and no I train people up to
groups of 50 people so and people always
tell me whether it's one person 50 or 10
000 it's the same but it still gets me
nervous when I stood up and did the
speech infant attention that's a huge
man it's funny because in my company as
well there's a lot of people that we've
hired that have gone through really well
and worked themselves up the ranks but
they were working at McDonald's or
retail and and I think degrees are
becoming less and less important unless
you want to be a doctor or something in
which case absolutely I'd hope that
somebody could do a surgery on me yeah
as Duncan right training and been to the
right University is absolutely but
generally speaking in most professions
it's about just being good rather than
having a degree I like this as long as
I've got good life experience right you
know if someone's got a story and
they've perhaps been through some
hardship yeah you know that they're
amazing people because they've been
through you kind of they've overcome
something sometimes if you've been to
University you've never had any hardship
you know so yeah that can be quite
tricky yeah what's the division with the
property company then so Vision with the
property company have stepped away
Angela's running that the team are
amazing I go in that office and I truly
truly like a family to me because I
didn't have a family in Portugal so to
kind of correct one so I truly miss him
but my true Vision with that is to let
that run itself I cause chaos I go in
there with all these ideas of course
yeah and like every entrepreneur yeah
they chase me away yeah just leave us
alone go away the people to tidy up the
maps that you created as an entrepreneur
they call me chaos yeah I go in there
put the music on jump up and down for 10
minutes and they're like let's get on
the phone look after the club yeah so
I've stepped away from that for now and
I I truly have stepped away
um and I shouldn't use that term for now
but Angela said yeah she's going to run
that company and she is and there's a
great team you know Christina the CFO
which is amazing so The Layover on that
and now I'm concentrating on finding a
new way to help people and pay back well
even being on this podcast is helping
people because it's being an inspiration
it's giving people you know a lot of
golden nuggets what do you think you've
invested in and you've been involved in
a lot of property deals in 23 different
countries what do you think the best
country is for property investment right
now Portugal backfire really yeah
because am I missing out then it's one
of them I've invested in quite a lot of
different countries now Ghana
specifically as well heavily invested in
Ghana I'm investing in quite a few
different countries 95 of my properties
are in the UK but I've not done anything
in Portugal so talk to me about Portugal
Investments then so Portugal I mean
people don't realize how good it is it's
a sleeping giant so everyone looks at
Spain because the price point but
there's some absolute Bargains in
Portugal and the biggest thing for me
with that is it's a safe investment
there's no big companies in there no big
Developers
and if we look at the the numbers there
if you because we have to use a
comparison but if you look at say the
Costa Del Sol there's over a million
properties for sale you look at the
Algarve there's only around 16 000 for
sale but yeah Portugal you can still get
80 90 Finance I can get 100 Finance I
can walk in there there's an apartment
for sale at the minute that I'm kind of
chasing I'm 154 000 Euros because I'm
cluster's Portuguese 100 Finance why
would you not buy it you know those
long-term rental market I advertised one
property for a thousand Euros a month
two bed two bath apartment 77 people
applied for it yeah it's insane how much
would the interest rates be there on
that like four percent you say four
percent so you're going to be paying so
if you're renting out for a grand how
much you're going to be paying on the
interest payments you probably cash
flowing around about 400 euros a month
and how are you getting 100 Finance the
bank repossession for people from the UK
you can get 90 Finance really on a bank
represent like I I brought a property in
valderlobo I paid 410 for it they lent
me 100 of the money then I had to light
refurb
um I got one of my team members to do it
and then furnished it 16 000 Euros
rented it out three grand a week and a
week in High season right and kept it
for three years sell it on the market
every all real estate should always be
up for sale everything's for sale
everything's for sale so yeah put it for
sale for 600 000. someone came in paid
five seven five they're happy I'm happy
I moved that money to another property
and that's the way I should work that's
great that's right the best one I've got
is my own personal house I brought this
pink house in the middle of nowhere it
was like a Barbie house I brought it
from the bank for 4 20. they lent me 90
percent
they were really strict on the mortgage
and they made me run on a treadmill I
couldn't even run yeah
medical for the mortgage yeah that is
classic because I probably this is a
residential yeah well it wasn't a
residential it was just that bank at
that time we're like just over strict
I'd have been screwed a year ago I
wouldn't know about anything I was like
running 2014 15. those oh this one was
19 2019. I weighed 20 kilos more yeah
and I was smoking 20 facts a day and I
was drinking I never do that anymore and
I'm trying to run on the treadmill and
it lent me 90 the numbers on it were 4
20. and then brought another 200 000 to
do a refurb on it and I was always
worried about not being able to afford
the mortgage and while it was getting
built we had to move out of our rented
house and the Alcove so expensive to
stay in the summer we went off to
Thailand took the kids yeah and then
next year I thought I remember what you
said and I thought I'll make it serviced
accommodation holiday lips yeah and I
brought my rentals manager around at the
time and said can you get me three grand
a week six
okay six so we went off to Thailand
again then we went to Vietnam and last
year the numbers on it are I mean it's
on the if I'm I'll be totally honest
it's probably worth 2.5 million
it's on the market for 2.9 it's what you
made over 2 million on it yeah
and then last year it rented out for 83
000 for seven weeks
it's the numbers are just crazy that is
insane yeah and then I don't have to pay
anyone because I've got the management
company thank God you were able to run
on that treadmill I know I know and I
was sweating I was like two million
pounds if you keep going
I had to run faster
that's nuts did you say you've done a
bit of rent to rent as well yeah I did
one and that was to help a client oh the
numbers on that he always received about
2 000 a month so I just understand sorry
when you said to help a client out what
do you mean so he's a client who brought
a property from us 10 years ago yeah he
needed a bit of refurbing he's a friend
of mine lovely guy called Graeme and I
went you know what gives you Villa I'll
give you two randomly it's sorry it's
just an interesting perspective because
most people say
how do you get rent to rent how do you
persuade landlords but you're saying I
just need to help him out yeah it's a
different mentality though in business
when you're thinking about helping
people as opposed to thinking how can I
get a deal oh no it's a different
mentality so just interesting language
that you use to other yeah I think if
you think like that you've got to help
people and you with the way you teach
that and taught me that was you exhaust
every opportunity right so we're great
and I said let's just get
I don't know your pool fixed let's get
your house repainted and he's like oh
well I have to keep flying across here
all right well I'll get someone to do it
and there he goes well
keep on it Chris I'm like I'm kind of
busy here great yeah I'm trying to look
after 50 staff 150 support staff for the
company because the 50 staff when I say
we've got 50 they're paid employees
they're not commission only people yeah
then there's another 150 cleaners
maintenance people so I'm trying to look
after all that and then Graham's like
did you get I'm like Graham you know
what we truly get on like a house on
fire he's hilarious and I said let me
just rent it from you you can use it so
you can you use it one two weeks of the
Year even his daughter and his family so
so you still use it just let me take
care of it and then we went in we
brought some new furniture started
renting it out
but the yield on it is insane so what I
do is I claim I'll be asking me for more
money that's fine okay
you won't mind because you took the pain
away yeah so I give it away to people
for free yeah so I say you can stay here
pay him 2 000 a month and what profit
does it bring you in
um probably 200 000. 200 000 pounds
profit because what I do is I put people
in there say you stay in the villa and
then they're looking for a property some
people buy some people don't but they
stay there for a week's holiday and they
go oh
can you show us a property to buy yeah
oh yes yeah and then you sell them deals
yeah wow yeah so you're making money
every which way and helping everybody at
the same time the worst case scenario is
it cost me 500 a week and I give it away
for free it's cost me 500. so there's
there's a massive upside and it helps
people all right that's awesome it all
it all started from taking them out for
dinner and we went on a beautiful dinner
in a restaurant and
um yeah and just went I'll get the bill
so what's your experience been like on
the academy you talked about the
one-time pass course yes sir I really
love the academy there's so much high
energy there yeah you know and other
people talking about other property
trainers and I'm like no no no no
you want to go to some leads it's high
energy amazing people I mean I met a
lovely couple Carly and Daly yeah a nice
couple really nice couple they were
working at Tesla and they're still at
Tesla and they helped me buy my brother
a car you know after his illness so I
kept in touch and now we're doing
different businesses together and I
brought them to the Tony Robbins event
to help me do a charity event to raise
money for the orphanage that's great and
she organized and daily organized that
in a day
and we've we're on target with that one
to raise
and I mean on the night we raised seven
thousand we've got a promise from a
donor to give 250
000 dollars to charity to Africa so they
helped do that that's great so the
academy I'm just blown away with it I
went to the academy dinner had a
fantastic time I've only done
two things with the academy and when you
you let me stand up and I met Russell
and Monica they're lovely people and
they've reserved some properties and
they've got a special deal because
they're Academy members and I took them
to Tony Robbins as well wow yes so
they're absolutely buzzing lovely people
a lot of it is about the network isn't
it it's not just what you know it's who
you know so you know in terms of
obviously the academy you've got the
mentorship and stuff you can book as
many mentoring calls as you want you've
got the training but the community and
the network is just you know you make
you do one deal it's it's it's paid for
itself so final words of wisdom for
anyone watching this is thinking I'm
really inspired Chris I wanna get into
property I want to think bigger I want
to get my first deal over the line what
from all of your experience over the
years in property and for what you've
done what would be your best piece of
advice mindset is everything but I would
say proximity Is Power you know I I've
got next to some of the the nicest
kindest people in the world you know and
it's about
being in that environment yeah if you
want to get into property go see some
real estate agents yeah right that's it
go and talk to me absolutely don't be
afraid be Fearless yeah push yourself I
love comfort zone if you really want to
get into property I took my team
skydiving every week and throwing people
out of a plane and jumping with them and
that is the best thing yeah that's why a
bungee jump yes
because it's like you need to train your
mind that when you're afraid you have to
just do it anyway yes and in property
you have to act quick as well all the
time be fast when a deal comes along you
gotta back quick everyone everyone
thinks you know I'll sleep on it I'll
speak to this person speak to that
person you're not committing to
necessarily having to buy it but just
move quick go for it go for it yeah go
for it make your move let's go Chris I
appreciate you coming out thank you so
much I really appreciate it not just
coming on the show but also I appreciate
your you know your humility as well and
what you've done and and remembering
where you've come from honoring those
that have helped you along the way it's
been an absolute pleasure I truly just
wanted to say thank you and you know I'm
happy to share my story share some quite
vulnerable information but that's the
key in it being vulnerable yeah being
honest so thank you respect Chris thank
you thank you so much
[Music]
thank you